the IRS breach was bigger than initially
reported I feel like there's going to be
another shoe to drop this doesn't just
end after one revision does it oh no the
problem is that after you've suffered a
breach when you begin to analyze the
scope of the damage unless you're
willing to declare your entire database
as an emergency zone the truth is you're
going to find as time goes on that more
and more people than you originally
thought were victimized so what point if
at all can IRS say that the fallout has
been contained well look at it this way
there's only so many people that
specific database they get transcript
database but the real issue here is that
is the failure of government as a whole
and the failure of many parts of the
business community to actually get this
thing under control and they're under
resourced we're under trained we're
under focused and we don't even
understand that thus the magnitude of
the threat that really faces ever yeah
until we can't keep getting more
instances in incidents I imagined though
the IRS in particular though is an
especially juicy target because of the
reams of data the huge volume of
information available on each household
more so than perhaps other government
agencies that's true but the office of
personal management now that was the
juiciest target of all because it not
only had the normal things that you
associate with personal identifying
information but it had the results of
the investigative reports not to mention
1.1 million fingerprints for
intelligence operatives around the world
and other government employees and
contractors but the real issue here is
that we're dealing with a situation
where government just hasn't focused
properly we can't get the senate to pass
the cybersecurity law they can't even
agree on what a cybersecurity law should
be they can't even agree on what privacy
should be in this country so i mean this
is the real crux of the problem add to
that the fact that there have been so
many breaches you're talking about over
1 billion file some people think that
was just last year but 1 billion files
that's what we know that we know about
that have already been breached or
improperly exposed to unauthorized
access so the data is there in the case
of this particular database for the IRS
they didn't do
heavily sophisticated thing that caused
them to crawl into systems it wasn't
difficult they walked through the front
door using data that had been collected
from all the other breaches that have
happened for so many years I mean in
this year alone we had anthem we had
premiera we had care first with the
office of personal management over 100
million Social Security numbers add to
that all of the information on social
networking sites where people pour their
hearts out yeah telling everybody
everything from their favorite band
their favorite color the school that
they went to for high school the mascot
all of these things so you're talking
about one Domino falling any others kind
of following as well given all that
companies and governments are behind and
trying to to get ahead of the problem
the response becomes critical who's
better at responding the private sector
or the public sector nobody that's the
real problem is that very few people
have really gotten it right and you have
to respond with urgency transparency and
empathy but now the burden unfortunately
has fallen on consumers is that each and
every one of us has to focus on what i
call the 3 m's we not only have to
minimize our exposure by keeping control
of as much data as we can but when it's
inevitably breached we have to focus on
ways to monitor and ways to manage the
damage okay well speaking of monitoring
in every instance of identity theft you
hear about how everyone supposed to
check their credit reports so you go and
do that what kind of proactive
monitoring or what kind of initiatives
can the credit reporting agencies like
Equifax do on their end well there are
new programs that have been developed
which we call instant alerts which
instead of the old days where they would
say scarlet somebody open an account
using your information was it you mm-hmm
they now can say to you in many
instances somebody is in the process of
trying to open an account right now oh
it's still reactive well no it's still
reactive but the truth is that that's
why you have to talk about more than
just credit monitoring you need what
they call identity or fraud monitoring
which tracks your data and if there's
any anomaly in your data if your address
changes your phone numbers change
something about your work changes you
should be notified just to make sure
that it's absolutely you because in
order to do identity theft
someone has to recreate you and it's in
that data recreation process when the
game begins and that's why you need to
know as quickly as possible if anybody
is in there crawling around on with your
data so Adam how much of my personal
information should I assume that
identity thieves already have access to
and are just waiting to deploy you have
to assume everything that's the problem
is there so much information that your
identity information is already
compromised I have no doubt that my
information is out there and that's why
it's my responsibility to be watching on
a daily basis every which way I can
whether i'm looking at credit reports
credit scores i sign up for alerts at my
bank to notify me when there's activity
i look for more sophisticated ways of
monitoring and i also have a damage
control program in place to help me if
there's a problem alright